guitare électrique et attitudes
provocantes
le peer gynt d'irina brook est une rock
star ambitieux et insolent une version
décalée du drame poétique norvégien de
1876 imaginé par la metteur en scène à
19 ans j'avais lu la pièce j'avais été
absolument
j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire parce que
c'est extraordinaire fin de conte de
fées mythique et existentielle aventures
d'une vie extraordinaire et donc à
l'époque je me suis dit mme bien que je
sois pas du tout metteur en scène serait
génial de faire une production de cette
pièce comme un opéra rock avec iggy pop
et david bowie un rêve d'adolescente
devenu presque réalité en 2012
iggy pop a composé deux morceaux du
spectacle chanteurs danseurs comédiens
et musiciens se côtoient pendant les
deux heures de show avec un casting
international et ses listes en day in
var sigurdsson acteur de cinéma et de
théâtre qui incarne le personnage
torturé de pizzi handan challenge de
jouer pierre guînes comme une rock star
des sujets de pierre clint est toujours
le même
ida propos de lego et comment les goûts
peut devenir destructeur j'ai la chance
de jouer seul mais qui est le symbole de
la pureté mais de jouer aussi à la
princesse des trolls qui est justement
l'opposé qui devient ensuite une vieille
sorcière hargneuse et horrible et c'est
un peu le voyage de perkins et le voyage
de cet homme qui cherche qui il est
qu'est ce que c'est le soin qu'est ce
que c'est d'être un être humain qui
suis-je c'est la question posée tout au
long de la comédie irina brook
définissons peer gynt comme une pièce
épique musical tout en conservant la
profondeur métaphysique
original un résultat moderne et
électriques joué au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines jusqu'au
samedi 21